[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
Katja Stresow ist wieder mit mir im
Studio später mit dem sportlichen Teil
der Sendung mit ganz viel Fußball
schönen guten Abend und das haben wir
heute unter anderem für Sie vorbereitet
vorsichtiges aufatmen weltweit reagieren
die Finanzmärkte nervös letztlich aber
stabil auf die Übernahme der Kredit
Suisse durch die UBS
Warnungen des Weltklimarates bei einem
weiter so ist eine Begrenzung der
Erderwärmung um 1,5 Grad praktisch
unmöglich
und Chancen und Risiken künstlicher
Intelligenz der Ethikrat mahnt KI darf
den Menschen unterstützen ihn aber nicht
ersetzen
[Musik]
wir beginnen mit der Schweizer
Bankenkrise die Geldhäuser Investoren
und Sparer auch hier bei uns ziemlich
anspannend nach der notübernahme der
Großbank Kredit Suisse durch den
landesrivalen UBS ist bis jetzt kein
finanzbeben zu erkennen an den
internationalen Börsen Nervosität aber
keine Panik fest steht die UBS übernimmt
die Kredit Suisse für umgerechnet rund 3
Milliarden Euro steht gerade für
Verluste von bis zu 5 Milliarden Euro
unterstützt wird der Deal von der
Schweizer Nationalbank mit mindestens
100 Milliarden und der Staat haftet
zusätzlich mit rund 9 Milliarden Euro
über den vorläufigen Ausgang des
hochfinanzkrimis Andreas linke
am Züricher Paradeplatz sind die beiden
geldhäuse Nachbarn zwei der 30
wichtigsten Banken der Welt bis gestern
viele Schweizer sind schon länger
skeptisch gegenüber ihren
Finanzinstituten
gestern haben beerdigt und heute wird
noch diskutiert ob man sich noch Boni
auszahlt für die Beerdigung das ist
sicherlich eine Image eine Image
natürlich oder das Vertrauen müssen wir
einfach hoffen dass sie in die Schweizer
Banken bestehen bleibt
wie viel trägt die am Sonntag in einer
Art notfallaktion beschlossene Übernahme
zum Vertrauen bei die Kredit Suisse
Aktionäre wurden schließlich nicht
gefragt und der Deal kann Staat und
Nationalbank viel Geld kosten auch diese
Lösung hat Risiken aber die Risiken für
den Staat für die SteuerzahlerInnen die
Steuerzahler sind deutlich geringer als
bei jedem anderen Szenario
credit swissaktionäre erhalten Anteile
der UBS die zu dem gesamten Deal
gedrängt werden musste Regierung Banken
Nationalbank und Finanzaufsicht hatten
fast ununterbrochen beraten die
Schweizer bankkultur ist natürlich ein
heiliges national gut von daher ist ganz
klar sie werden es in den Griff bekommen
aber die neue Bank die UBS ist so groß
wer soll die noch retten wenn was
passiert denn die aktuelle Bilanzsumme
der neuen mega-bank entspricht etwa dem
Doppelten des Schweizer
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das sehen die
Eidgenossen nicht ohne Unbehagen
wir gehen zu Valerie Haller nach
Frankfurt an die Börse Valerie wie viel
von dieser Krise ist jetzt wirklich vom
Tisch also von der Credit Suisse geht
vermutlich keine imminente Gefahr mehr
aus wie bricht nicht unkontrolliert
zusammen das hätte auch eine weltweite
Finanzkrise auslösen können also die Kuh
die ist vom Eis entsprechend sieht es an
der Börse aus der Dax hat ordentlich
Aufwind mit über einem Prozent die
Bankenwerte die erholen sich deutlich
langsamer und das ist schon ein Hinweis
darauf dass noch erhebliche Zweifel
bestehen ob da nicht doch noch
irgendwelche Zeitbomben schlummern wenn
auch Politik und Notenbanker fast schon
gebetsmühlenartig wiederholen wie robust
der deutsche Bankensektor ist ja Banken
haben heute dickere Finanzpolster für
den Notfall Vorschrift seit der
Finanzkrise aber was ist mit den vielen
amerikanischen Regionalbanken gibt es da
noch Turbulenzen die vielleicht hier
herüberschwappen ja und was ist mit dem
Erbe der Kredits sie hat Anleihen im
Milliarden wert herausge wer hat wie
viele davon im Depot keiner weiß es
immerhin stehen potenziell 16 Milliarden
Euro im Feuer also Beruhigung fürs erste
Jahr doch ganz ausgestanden ist die
Geschichte noch nicht danke für deine
Einordnung valerial aber das es ist ein
Besuch bei dem jeder Schritt jede Geste
international aufmerksam beobachtet wird
erstmals seit dem russischen Angriff auf
die Ukraine ist Chinas staatschefski zu
Gast in Moskau dem in vielen
Weltregionen isolierten Präsidenten
Putin bringt die Visite erst einmal
Bilder zweier Partner die sich verstehen
inhaltlich dürfte es wohl vor allem um
Handelsfragen gehen Chinas Rolle
zwischen Ost und West und vor allem um
den Krieg das der Ukraine Krieg
ausgebrochen ist dafür gibt Peking dem
Westen die Schuld inszeniert sich aber
gleichzeitig als neutraler Vermittler
obwohl China und Russland voneinander
profitieren herrscht ein Ungleichgewicht
es ist eine komplexe Partnerschaft Achse
Konrad hat die Fakten
Russland und China hier das größte da
das bevölkerungsreichste Land der Erde
zwei Supermächte die viel eint und die
voneinander profitieren Stichwort Handel
vergangenes Jahr ist der um 30%
gestiegen Öl und Gas aus Russland sind
für das wachstumshungrige China so
billig wie nie und Russland nimmt seit
den westlichen Sanktionen von China was
ist kriegen kann und hofft auch auf
Waffen für Russland ist China
Handelspartner Nummer eins umgekehrt
gilt das nicht
Stichwort Geostrategie Russland und
China zwei Mächte mit Expansion Strang
und einem gemeinsamen Gegner dem das
nicht passt die USA das gemeinsame Ziel
eine Chinesisch russisch dominierte
Weltordnung
Stichwort Politik und Gesellschaft beide
eins die Ablehnung westlich liberaler
Werte die Verherrlichung eines
autoritären ein Personenkults und die
Verfolgung von Andersdenkenden Russland
braucht China viel mehr als umgekehrt
China dagegen darf nur so
russlandfreundlich sein dass es seine
westlichen Handelspartner nicht
verprellt
wir wollen Nachfragen bei Elisabeth
Schmidt in Peking und Christian Sam in
Moskau zunächst zu dir Christian ein
bemerkenswert langer Besuch aus China
warum ist er so wichtig für Moskau
Wladimir Putin ist dieser Besuch sehr
wichtig aus mehreren Gründen zum einen
wir haben die Bilder gerade gesehen
Putin braucht diesen symbolischen
Schulterschluss mit dem mächtigen
Partner aus China um dem Westen der
eigenen Bevölkerung und
ja der internationalen Gemeinschaft zu
zeigen dass man doch nicht so isoliert
ist wie der Westen das gerne propagiert
und das vielleicht auch gerne hätte und
dass man sagen kann man kann eben noch
verhandeln man hat eben noch
verlässliche Partner man hat sozusagen
auch treue Freunde die Freundschaft
wurde auch immer wieder betont und der
Handel wurde im Bericht ja auch schon
angesprochen ist natürlich ganz wichtig
für Russland gerade zu existenziell das
Volumen ist ja gestiegen seit dem
Angriff auf die Ukraine und beide Länder
da ist man sich im Vorfeld auch schon
eigentlich wissen und sind auch in der
Lage diesen Handeln noch zu
intensivieren und da werden die beiden
Delegationen morgen intensiv darüber
verhandeln weiter nach Peking zu dir
Elisabet welches Interesse verfolgt sie
was erhoff Peking sich von dieser visite
sie sind wegen Jesus tatsächlich auch um
eine Image Pflege und das gleich in
zweierlei Hinsicht einmal gegenüber dem
kriegsmüden Europa wir haben es gehört
russland hat China die letzten das
letzte Jahr unterstützt und der Ruf ist
ziemlich angeknackst China braucht aber
unbedingt europäische Hightech vor allem
bei der Halbleitertechnologie
chipfertigungsmaschinen die auf unter
die westlichen Sanktionen fallen vor dem
Hintergrund riesengroße Wirtschaftskrise
im eigenen Land und zweitens China
befindet sich auch auf globaler
Imagekampagne es hat auch etwas
mitgebracht im Gepäck einen
diplomatischen Erfolg wir haben letzte
Woche gab es einen Durchbruch zwischen
Iran und Saudi-Arabien unter der
Vermittlung China sie wollen wieder
diplomatische Beziehungen aufnehmen und
die Botschaft dahinter ist ganz klar
china will langfristig die USA als
führende Weltmacht ablösen da würde
natürlich der nächste Kuh sein eine
Vermittlung zwischen der Ukraine und
Russland wie ernsthaft China das ganze
nimmt das wird sich in den nächsten
Tagen auch daran zeigen ob es ein
weiteres Gespräch geben wird nämlich
zwischen Ski und dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski es gibt Berichte
darüber aber bislang keine offizielle
Bestätigung vielen Dank nach Peking auch
nach Moskau Elisabeth und Christian
während Russland und China also Nähe
demonstrieren vereinbart die EU ein
milliardenschweres munitionspaket für
die Ukraine die europäischen Außen- und
Verteidigungsminister beschlossen in den
kommenden zwölf Monaten eine Million
Artillerie Geschosse nach Kiew zu
liefern Nachschub der wohl dringend
gebraucht wird mehr von Ulf Roller
Achtung Feuer ruft der ukrainische
Soldat der Kampf um bachmut ist eine
Materialschlacht am Ende entscheidet
auch wer genug Munition hat und da ist
die ukrainische Armee der russischen
unterliegen die EU will helfen will
Munition beschaffen vor allem geht es um
Artilleriegeschosse
wir müssen der Ukraine schnell Munition
liefern und wir müssen mehr liefern das
alles müssen wir zu einem akzeptablen
Preis für die EU hinbekommen darum geht
es
die EU will rund 2 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung stellen die Mitgliedstaaten
die aus ihrem nationalen Beständen
Munition an die Ukraine abgeben werden
von diesem Geld entschädigt außerdem
will die EU Munition kaufen innerhalb
eines Jahres sollen so eine Million
Schuss für die Ukraine zur Verfügung
stehen die Zeit drängt die Ukraine sagt
sie brauche jetzt schon neue Munition
Ziel muss sein das hat absolute
Priorität aus meiner Sicht das noch in
diesem Fall noch in diesem Jahr eine
nennenswerte Zahl von entsprechender
Munition in die Ukraine geliefert wird
Rüstungskonzerne wie rein Metall bauen
ihre Produktionsstätten aus die
Industrie hofften nun auf Aufträge der
EU das müssen die Verträge vergeben
werden ja also wir produzieren auch ohne
Verträge aber ich kann natürlich nicht
Milliarden vorfinanzieren ja sondern nur
ein begrenztes Maß
zeitenwände in Europa die EU wird zum
Waffen und munitionslieferanten
nach dem Krieg in der Ukraine noch ein
Thema dass die ganze Welt angeht die
Erderwärmung und da kommt heute wenig
Erfreuliches von führenden Experten der
Weltklimarat sagt das Klima auf unserem
Globus erwärmt sich noch stärker als
bisher berechnet das angestrebte
Klimaziel eine maximale Erwärmung um 1,5
Grad das werde voraussichtlich schon
zwischen 2030 und 35 erreicht Marc Hugo
und Inga Rabe
kaum Wasser in den Seen ausgetrocknete
Flussbette staubige Felder und kein
Regen in Sicht schon jetzt zu Beginn des
Jahres herrscht in Südeuropa eine
heftige Dürre der Klimawandel ist
angekommen
die klima-zeitbombe tickt der heutige
Bericht aber ist eine Anleitung zur
Entschärfung der Bombe eine Anleitung
wie die Menschheit überleben kann
Dürre in Europa Waldbrände in Chile
schwere Überschwemmungen in Pakistan die
Folgen des Klimawandels sind jetzt schon
heftiger als erwartet fast die Hälfte
der Menschheit ist direkt von den
Auswirkungen betroffen der weltweite
Klimaschutz reicht dabei bei weitem noch
nicht aus der
Treibhausgas-Ausstoß muss bis 2030 fast
halbiert werden um die Klimaziele von
Paris noch zu erreichen wir haben nur
noch ein begrenztes Zeitfenster um auf
dieser Welt eine lebenswerte
die Zukunft zu sichern für die nächsten
Generationen für die Natur und und die
Verantwortung liegt bei der heutigen
Generation liegt bei den jetzigen
Verantwortungsträgern je langsamer wir
sind uns auf Nachhaltigkeit umzustellen
desto mehr müssen wir uns künftig
einschränken um Klima zu schützen der
Klimawandel ein weltweites Problem das
gemeinsam bekämpft werden muss zum
Beispiel durch Kooperationen mit ärmeren
Ländern hier im Südwesten Marokkos waren
die argan-bäume fast ausgerottet mit
internationaler Hilfe wurde massiv
wieder aufgeforstet
jahrgang-bäume nehmen nicht nur das
Treibhausgas CO2 aus der Luft sondern
sind auch ein Bollwerk gegen
Wüstenbildung es sind Schritte wie diese
die notwendig sind im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel
ja wo stehen wir beim Klimawandel alle
wichtigen Zahlen Daten und Fakten zur
Erderwärmung gibt's zum Durchklicken in
der ZDF heute App
erstmals sollen im Sommer die Renten im
Osten Deutschlands auf dasselbe Niveau
wie im Westen steigen das hat das
Bundesarbeitsministerium mitgeteilt und
bekannt gegeben wie viel mehr es im
Sommer für Rentnerinnen und Rentner gibt
demnach steigt die Rente zum ersten Juli
in Westdeutschland um 4,39 Prozent und
in den östlichen Bundesländern um
5,86%. die Deutsche Rentenversicherung
verzeichnet aktuell eine sehr gute
Kassenlage
apropos Renten in Frankreich hat dieses
Thema eine politische Krise ausgelöst
und ist dort heute ein ziemlich
spannender Abend die Regierung muss sich
zur Stunde wegen ihrer umstrittenen
Rentenreform eine Misstrauensvotum
stellen die erste Abstimmung hat sie vor
wenigen Minuten denkbar knapp
überstanden eine zweite folgt noch bei
diesem Antrag gilt eine Mehrheit aber
nahezu als ausgeschlossen damit wäre die
Rentenreform von Präsident macron
endgültig verabschiedet sie sieht unter
anderem vor das renteneintrittsal von 62
auf
64 Jahre zu erhöhen
eine wichtige neue Studie kommt aus
Leipzig in Kinderheimen der DDR haben
viele Mädchen und Jungen seelische und
körperliche Vernachlässigung erlebt ein
Großteil wurde körperlich misshandelt
und die Hälfte der Befragten einer
Stichprobe berichtet auch von sexuelle
Missbrauch in Kinderheimen der DDR waren
etwa eine halbe Million Kinder und
Jugendliche untergebracht
Solidarität wie in der ersten Stunde das
verspricht die EU den Opfern des
schweren Erdbebens in der Türkei und
Syrien heute lud sie zu einer
internationalen Geberkonferenz insgesamt
wurden 7 Milliarden Euro zugesagt
Deutschland erhöht seine Hilfe auf knapp
240 Millionen Euro Geld mit dem auch der
Wiederaufbau in den Krisengebieten
beider länderfinanziert werden soll in
der Türkei verfolgt die Regierung dabei
einen ehrgeizigen einjahresplan Jörg
Brase hat sich in der Region Gaziantep
angeschaut wie es voran geht
hier die kleine Küche ein Bad der
Schlafraum viel besser als das Zelt in
dem wir vorher saßen sagt Willy Celik
vier Leute teilen sich den Container es
ist warm und trocken und sie haben Strom
immerhin
wir könnten uns im Moment keine eigene
Unterkunft leisten wir haben alles
verloren für ein neues Haus haben wir
überhaupt kein Geld
ihre Heimatstadt wurde vom Beben dem
Erdboden gleichgemacht ein paar
Kilometer entfernt entsteht nun eine
Container statt für und 7000 Menschen es
soll schnell gehen dass jedenfalls
verspricht der türkische Präsident
werden wir 100.000 Container aufstellen
und eine halbe Million Erdbebenopfer in
diesen Gebieten unterbringen dort werden
sie erst mal unter besseren Bedingungen
leben können
noch leben viele in Zelten bereits nach
einem Jahr aber so der Präsident sollen
hunderttausende neue Wohnungen und
Häuser bezugsfertig sein um die Häuser
dieser Menschen wieder aufzubauen bittet
die türkische Regierung um Hilfe der
Europäer durfte die EU Flüchtlingshilfe
nur für ganz bestimmte Projekte
eingesetzt werden will die türkische
Regierung diesmal selbst entscheiden
wofür sie die Hilfsgelder ausgibt
so sollen Banken den Betroffenen kleinen
Kredite geben um ihre Geschäfte wieder
zu eröffnen Schulden sollen gestundet
oder ganz gestrichen werden ganze Städte
müssen wieder aufgebaut werden eine
Mammutaufgabe die viele Milliarden Euro
kosten wird
künstliche Intelligenz entwickelt sich
rasant und ist enger mit unserem Leben
verknüpft als viele ahnen die
Technologie hilft Ärzten bei der
Diagnose schreibt alleine Texte und
lässt Maschinen aus Erfahrungen lernen
jetzt hat sich der Ethikrat Gedanken zum
verantwortungsvollen Umgang mit
künstlicher Intelligenz gemacht die
wichtigste Erkenntnis sie darf den
Menschen nicht ersetzen Sven Ricken ich
bin hier heute um über ein Thema zu
sprechen das für viele von uns von
großer Bedeutung geschädigt GPT ist
inzwischen wohl in jedem Klassenzimmer
angekommen Schüler und Lehrer haben mit
dem ki-programm das fertige Texte
schreiben kann schon viel ausprobiert
die neue Version GPT 4 ist erst wenige
Tage auf dem Markt und greift auf noch
komplexeres Wissen zurück das Programm
könnte im ersten Schritt wohl den
Kundendienst vieler Unternehmen
übernehmen für den integrat wäre das nur
okay wenn das System ausschließlich
assistiert
der Einsatz von KI die Delegation an die
Maschine muss menschliche Entfaltung
Autorschaft
Handlungsmöglichkeiten erweitern und
darf sie nicht vermindern am Hamburger
Uniklinikum kann eine KI steigenden
Hirndruck von Intensivpatienten
vorhersagen und das zwei Stunden im
Voraus eine Hilfe für das Ärzteteam aber
auch eine große Frage darf die KI
irgendwann eingreifen und das hat
natürlich auch eine gewisse
brisanzrechtlich wer trägt die
Verantwortung wenn dieser Vorschlag
völlig daneben geht aber die
Entscheidung am Ende ist eine ärztliche
Entscheidung an manch andere
Anwendungsfelder von KI wird sich der
Mensch erst gewöhnen müssen solche
bildgeneratoren etwa Mission aus
Tausenden von Aufnahmen neue echt
aussehende Fotos in wenigen Sekunden man
kann heute de facto kaum noch
unterscheiden ob das Bild von einer KI
generiert wurde oder ob es sich um ein
echtes Foto handelt die Qualität ist
schon sehr sehr gut Fehler machen
allerdings noch beide Systeme Bild und
textgeneratoren auch das neue Chet gbt
etwa hat so seine Schwierigkeiten mit
der deutschen Politik der amtierende
Finanzminister Deutschlands ist Olaf
Scholz wie ich zuvor erwähnt habe ich
hoffe dass diese Antwort richtig ist und
entschuldige mich wieder für meine
vorherigen Fehler
nicht unfehlbar und wo wir schon bei
technischer Unterstützung sind Katja die
war gestern Abend auch in der
Fußball-Bundesliga nötig allerdings denn
die ein oder andere Zeitlupen
Wiederholung musste für Klarheit sorgen
in der Partie Bayer Leverkusen gegen
Bayern München und am Strich standen am
Ende zwei kuriose Elfmeter ein zwei zu
eins für Leverkusen und ein
unparteiischer im Fokus
Schiedsrichter Tobias Stieler nach dem
Spiel aufrichtig bezeichnet den
videoassistenten als seinen Lebensretter
denn nachdem der FC Bayern in der 22
minute durch Kimmich in Führung geht
will der Unparteiische nach dem
Seitenwechsel zweimal eine Schwalbe des
Leverkusen das Adli im Münchner
Strafraum gesehen haben beide Male muss
er seine Entscheidung nach Hinweis aus
Köln und Ansicht der Bilder revidieren
die daraus resultierenden Elfmeter
verwandelt palacius sicher Leverkusen
dreht die Begegnung gewinnt mit zwei zu
eins die Münchner geben vor dem
Spitzenspiel gegen Dortmund am 1 April
die Tabellenführung an den BVB ab
und alles zum 25 Spieltag zum Beispiel
eben dieses 2:1 von Leverkusen gegen
Bayern München online zu sehen bei uns
in ZDF heute.de und in der heute App und
noch dies in Frankfurt hat sich gestern
Abend die Nationalmannschaft erstmals
seit der verkorksten WM wieder
zusammengefunden heute gab es dann ein
Training denn am Samstag steht das erste
Testspiel des Jahres an in Mainz gegen
Peru mit dabei viele Neulinge und
Rückkehrer und ein Rudi Völler die
Zukunft hat begonnen der neue
Sportdirektor Rudi Völler und Hansi
Flick wollen ein titelfähiges Team
aufbauen und die Herzen der Fans
zurückgewinnen heute vor dreieinhalb
tausend eine erste schamoffensive beim
öffentlichen Training nicht dabei Jamal
Musala der verletzungsbedingt abreißte
dabei hat er gestern nach seiner
Einwechslung in Leverkusen bis zum Ende
durchgespielt doch heute dann die
Diagnose Muskelfaserriss im linken
Oberschenkel schade dass ich schon mal
nicht dabei ist und und wir wünschen
natürlich dass er so schnell wie möglich
wieder fit ist dass er möglichst nach
den Länderspiele nach den Länder Spielen
wieder wieder spielen kann ob musealer
bis zum Topspiel gegen Dortmund ist
fraglich
und das Länderspiel Deutschland Peru
übrigens live im ZDF Dankeschön Katja
und zum Schluss etwas Wichtiges
angesichts weltweiter Krisen wir reden
über das Glück das strahlt besonders
über den Finnen im Land der Polarlichter
sind die Menschen so happy wie nirgendwo
sonst zum sechsten Mal in Folge
Spitzenreiter sagt jedenfalls der
jährliche Glücks Bericht Faktoren etwa
soziales Miteinander und Gesundheit
Deutschland dagegen geht von Rang 14 auf
16 runter muss aber nicht so bleiben
heute ist ja Frühlingsanfang ist der
Teller neue Tage neues Glück
und das beginnt übrigens exakt um 22:24
Uhr also der astronomische frühlingstart
das Plus Wetteraussichten gleich mit
Katja Horne fahren wir empfehlen das
heute journal mit Christian Sievers um
21:45 Uhr schönen Dank und für Sie noch
einen schönen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend heute ist Tag und
Nachtgleiche astronomischer
Frühlingsbeginn ab sofort werden die
Tage länger als die Nächte und ein
Frühlings hoch gibt es auch das Hoch
Kali viele von uns hatten heute aber
trüben Himmel und es gab Regen und wir
regen Nachschub ist gesorgt von
Nordwesten schon heute Nacht setzt
kräftigere Regen in der zweiten
Nachthälfte im Nordwesten ein sonst
gibt's erstmal nur wenig Regen und im
Süden ist es zum Teil auch klar da
bildet sich Nebel das wird eine meist
milde Nacht mit Tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 9 Grad am Niederrhein und vier
Grad an der Ostsee Köder wird es in der
Oberpfalz und auch zwischen Allgäu und
Breisgau sinken die Werte auf 3 bis 0
Grad morgen geht's ein sehr deutliches
Süd nordgefälle bei den Temperaturen
mild richtig schon fast warm ist es an
der Donau am Neckar und am Oberrhein mit
16 bis 18 Grad sonst bleibt es bei 10
bis 14 Grad frischer denn vor allen
Dingen über Norddeutschland ziehen
morgen Regen Wolken hinweg und bis
mittags erreichen Sie die Lübecker Bucht
den Harz und den Thüringer Wald in
Süddeutschland dagegen ist es deutlich
freundlicher zum Teil richtig sonnig und
wechselhaft geht's auch in den nächsten
Tagen weiter mit Regenschauern und
Gewittern erst in Nordwesten später dann
aber auch Richtung Südosten guten Abend